hey what's happening man it's me aka
float man
check me out on the bootleg kid podcast
you dig what i'm saying it's up it's
gonna stay up you dig
yo it's the bootleg cab show special
guest in here
welcome k camp what's happening what's
up man ain't none kickin it kickin [ __ ]
like i always do uh i feel like man i
gotta give you some flowers cause i feel
like you're one of the more underrated
artists man in the show the last like
decade or so so we just had this talk uh
you know saying 10 minutes ago i say
undefeated now they underrate it yeah
man talk talk to me like um obviously
you've been on a run i feel like when
was when was cut that [ __ ] off like
2014 14. so we're going on seven eight
years now you know what i'm saying and i
feel like
you've just been so consistent with
putting out just for sure hits for sure
my bloodline at this point you know what
i'm saying yeah man like people gotta
know i make music do you feel like you
get enough credit though not yet it's
coming though
every every i feel like every artist go
through this [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like
even the drake's even you know saying
everybody went through that period of
time where all this [ __ ] been future he
went through it future definitely when
he went through it it was it was one
point is his tweet i'm trying to find to
this day
the future had tweeted he was like man
they [ __ ] keep playing with me
like i ain't dropping him you know they
just popping this [ __ ]
and i think like a year later that's
when future you know you know it's crazy
you said about him because i remember
having that conversation because future
put out tony montana yeah and magic he
was going crazy yeah but like people
really weren't paying attention until he
went on that mixtape run exactly he put
pluto out no one really cares exactly
you know what i'm saying like he has one
record no one cares exactly so i'll be
like that you know what i'm saying you
gotta just you gotta know where you at
as an artist know where you wanna be
mentally you know what i'm saying and
keep putting that work in until and [ __ ]
crap i feel like two you you have like a
bunch of different bags you could
you could tap into as an artist like you
put out like
like kiss five was crazy like when you
do um like something from the kiss
series it's more melodic more for the
ladies
compared to when you do
like your new album that's coming out is
it is it a different approach or is that
kind of the sh like give me that the
thought process behind like um with the
kids projects that's that's mainly r b
right you know what i'm saying it's
catering to my female fan base because
they love that [ __ ] you get what i'm
saying but when i really like creating
my albums like my first album i came out
with all the ways up
one way oh my you know what i'm saying
real
i wouldn't say not real album because
they all real but
it's a
you pulling from everywhere i'm making
i'm making trap [ __ ] i'm making [ __ ] for
that for the females i'm making vibe
[ __ ] i'm making [ __ ] for the club and
it's all one you know i'm saying
um project but kiss series just straight
female so i like to balance the bags
though but i'd rather do
everything you want so you like to just
do it all i like just make music and put
it all together and make it you know
saying make it flow the right way you
know it's all about the flow and just
the vibe of the project so you got to
really be
you know say mindful of what you put on
there and how that [ __ ] moving through
the project yeah i feel like too like
you know when you think of like just the
range of you as an artist you could cut
that [ __ ] off all the way to like a
record like comfortable mm-hmm it's
totally different right different worlds
yeah and and if you just go on your
spotify and pick whatever projects you
have a lot of people you got a lot of
discography
[ __ ] depending on what you listen to
you'll be like wait this is this the
same guy the show no it's facts yeah but
it been like that you know i'm saying
that just i'm a songwriter first
you get what i'm saying so it it it's to
the point where you can put any
instrumental in front of me and i'm just
i'm a vibe out on that [ __ ] i don't go
in the studio saying
i'm about to make this record right oh
this is what i'm on today i just
whatever i hear that's what i'm giving
that's fair man um what do you think has
held you back
from being like a superstar
myself
why and what why do you say that um me
being naive in the beginning you know
i'm saying not really listening to you
know saying the advice
people not everybody but you know i'm
saying it's a certain few people that
just told me certain things i should do
and what i shouldn't do but at the same
time i feel like this [ __ ] playing out
the way i wanted to play out you get
what i'm saying like i hear that all the
time by the superstar i should be bigger
than i should be bigger than what i am
now but what's bigger you know what i'm
saying like it's just
i think i think that when i think of k
camp i think of this guy's got a lot of
hit records yeah for sure i definitely
should be way you got hits but but but i
feel like that there's it's hard
it's you know i feel like the music part
is easy for you right yeah i feel like
the other the other side of it is like
it's the exposure it's the exposure how
do you get people to care about you
as long as my fans care i don't give a
damn who else cares right right right
long as i can set a lot of shows and and
continue to make money and put out great
bodies of work and and tour and do do
same [ __ ] the [ __ ] popping doing
make the same money all right listen
you're popping
[ __ ] up now to my entire life when you
say i hear what you're saying yeah you
know what i'm saying like
it's it's really just it's it's that
exposure man it's the media you know
what i'm saying once we tap in to like
you know the propaganda you know i don't
do that well you don't get into any of
the controversies exactly which is
a good thing that leads to yeah actually
looks you add some music on top
you know what i'm saying but i like to
stay in my lane and make sure my
business together to make sure
everything that's that's running on my
end is operating on on the right level
you mentioned uh being a songwriter
first um how often do you lend your pen
to other artists
recently not that much you know what i'm
saying because to the point where
i was just having this conversation the
other day um i had wrote a verse for
beyonce it's savage remix you know what
i'm saying but my verse didn't get used
and just off that simple fact of me
taking my time on my day to write some
[ __ ] and it don't get you i ain't got
time to be
you know what i'm saying just
pausing my day to get a placement so
i don't know it's it's if i get if i get
a call i'm you know saying say beyonce
around to call me right now and say come
to the studio
and write this
and pull up but i'm not about to do the
middle man send it to somebody he said
yeah no that's a the hustle and bustle
of the game it's like the producer game
i'd be feeling bad because producers be
really just chomping at the bit just to
get that placement to get that placement
you know what i'm saying and i ain't got
time for that if it's direct i'm with it
but as far as like
i ain't doing that run around so with
the beyonce situation someone had
reached out to a middle person that
reached out to you he really wasn't the
middle man he was he was the man right
but you know what i'm saying like before
that before i wrote that i ain't really
wrote nobody's [ __ ] in a minute i don't
even i always turn so you just submitted
a verse i was just doing he said beyonce
i was like [ __ ] all right right right
but you know saying when it didn't land
i'm like come on man you should've just
kept whoever you called first they got
diversity and i said let him just do it
you feel me but ain't no ain't no bad
feelings bad blood that's the game did
she do you know if she cut the verse or
no you don't know i never met beyonce
that'd be yeah i mean that'd be crazy
that'd be crazy though i'm gonna get one
though
who who like you know you mentioned
beyonce beyonce is a legend but like who
who are the artists that you still
aspire to be in the same room as that
you haven't yet met or worked with
[Music]
of um jay you know what i'm saying me
and me me and drake overdue
um
it's a lot man it's a lot of talented
artists in the game i still want to want
to tap in with you know saying i can
name a hundred artists you know what i'm
saying just the people that y'all ain't
heard me with yet you know what i'm
saying the thugs you know i'm saying
like people in my city that's you know
saying got a wave going people like me
and watch easter ain't got one i don't
know how to heal yeah you've been like
super tapped in on the west coast too
for years well yj was on the cut off
remix but they don't count
you know what i'm saying like a lot of
folks that i [ __ ] with on music you know
what i'm saying leveled i'm like [ __ ]
once that time come i'll never force
nothing i'll be in my own world i do my
own thing so
when that when that when that energy
happened it happened you know
uh talk about give me the rundown of
this new album you got some dope
features you got pnb rock music trey
songs yeah some r b features some yeah
yeah yeah the um um it's just the follow
up on kiss five you get what i'm saying
um i got one more deal until i'm fully
independent i'm not one more deal one
more project so i'm fully independent
so it's it's just a follow-up it's been
a year since i uh i dropped the album
the last album was the panda in the
pandemic you know what i'm saying did
very well in the pandemic but it's just
it's just time for me to you know
drop my nuts again so let me ask you
this you're going independent once the
deal's up
of course
i saw you at gazi's birthday party
that's my dog are you going to empire i
was already with empire okay so you're
going to after this
it's possible okay you guys were just
talking like two weeks ago i mean i'm
saying i saw you on his birthday yeah
yeah it's it's possible you know so i
really want to just get a feel for it i
ain't been independent since 2014 you
know i'm trying to get down because you
know uh like i said i run my own label i
got my whole whole situation we got our
own distribution
um marketing marketing team uh
playlist and team we got we got the
we got the whole nine independently so
you know so i just want to tap in and
see how much i can do by myself give me
your like uh run down because you know
you said uh i know one of your artists
is on your album but kind of tell me
like about your label the name and just
some of some of the artists you're
working with yeah rare sound is just you
know saying what it sounds like you feel
me um when i was staying out here in l.a
but like 2016 and it's in the 16
beginning of 17 we had moved back to
atlanta
we used to go by slums slumlords you
know saying that's always on that you
know saying all that [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
but we had to evolve you know what i'm
saying during that time i came with the
name rare you know so i was really just
speaking on my my behalf right i felt
like i was as an artist so i was rare
you know came back to atlanta you know
we've been building since 2017 since the
rare project i dropped in 11 the first
project i dropped when i moved back to
atlanta and it eventually turned into
rare sound and just it became a thing
where
you know saying we wanted to do we
wanted to do something that
hadn't been done before in the game as
far as like structuring the business
side right you know what i'm saying a
lot a lot of artists get trapped in
these deals and do all this you know
what i'm saying get get [ __ ] out of
money and you know saying we try to do
fair deals on on red sound in
we uh we give the artists full control
of creativity you know saying they do
what they want whoever the artist is
that's what the artist is going to be
you know saying we can always chime in
and help them out but
we let everybody beat him and
it's a win-win if you pop you're going
to get paid it ain't nobody eating your
pockets up there and we just trying to
assist you and get you going because
i went through the [ __ ] where my [ __ ]
was [ __ ] up and i don't want nobody
around me feeling the same way i felt
because that can either make or break
you right you know what i'm saying you
get into a [ __ ] up label situation you
might break your everybody out of
yourself everybody ain't mentally strong
they can't handle that much [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
by the grace of god i'm built like a
[ __ ] machine and i've been through a
lot of [ __ ] and i'm still here still
still hustling and still better than
ever but on the red sound end we try to
do fair deals and like i said we got our
own distribution so whenever you want to
draw it's like you got free reigns what
the [ __ ] you want you're going to drop
every [ __ ] day we ain't going to tell
you we ain't going to inspect it but if
you want to drop every day
you got that you got the range too hey
interrupting the interview to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks now
as you can see i always have my odd
socks on baby you know what i'm saying
oh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssoxofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks these are the
outsiders you know what i'm saying they
got spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssoxofficial.com use
the keyword bootleg kev at checkout and
you'll save 20
off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddsofficial.com keyword bootleg kevin
checkout save 20 what were some
situations or some things that you had
to learn
kind of like the hard way in the music
game
was it some pub [ __ ] was it the label
[ __ ] man it was all the [ __ ] right it
was all the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying not reading contracts just
being just being blind to the money you
know saying money coming in and not
really taking care of business and the
business end up biting me in the ass few
years later and i had to clean up the
business
and for the past couple years when
people thought i was gone i was cleaning
up the business
you know what i'm saying and that took
time to this day i'm still you know
saying everything is back how i need to
be right right but it takes time to
really like take some [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
up and fix it put all the pieces
together by yourself you know what i'm
saying like really like locked in on
some
you know some pinky in the brain and
[ __ ] right
you feel me so
but i can't complain these days
would you say like um because a lot of
artists like you said they'll they'll
get a deal and they won't worry so much
about the terms but they'll
maybe they'll get that front-end advance
yeah of course and they're like yes it's
beautiful the front-end advance is
beautiful you know what i'm saying but
it ain't
right but
for people who don't know like what is
because i always try to tell artists
like look like an advance is cool but
it's not it's really all that matters
are your terms because you got to pay
that money back you got to give it back
you got to give it back and it's most of
the time it's at a really bad rate
and you know i think a lot of young
artists they make that mistake where
they run to whoever you always hear
about bidding wars and [ __ ] you'll be
like well who's got the biggest advance
yeah sometimes it ain't it's mo it's not
about that for the rain because you you
can get uh you can get a large ass
advance and don't you know saying don't
succeed on the other side i mean you
talk about yg you know
i was talking to yg i mean this is on
video so it's not like this he's like i
haven't seen any money off my music for
real yeah he probably got a crazy thing
yeah no because he signed with def jam
and he just re-upped but before that
like he was like bro like yeah when he
was unhappy with dev jam it was because
he probably
crazy yeah yeah i know yo you got you
know so you gotta have them there's
somebody with platinum records yeah i
would never thought that you know saying
you got to have them good lawyers on
your you know saying you got to be in
communication with your lord you can
have a lawyer but if you ain't talking
to him yeah young blue just told us that
right yeah young blue was like i got
three in the uh three was it with
columbia he had three gold records he
said i ain't can't check a lot of folks
go through that same [ __ ] yeah but you
gotta go through you know say it's real
at the end of the day is how long you're
gonna you're gonna stand for that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it's also like
would you rather have the quick nut or
like the consistent residual bag every
month exactly i take the residual bag
yep you get what i'm saying but i went
to the same phase you know i'm saying
during that time during that 2016 17th
period i ain't see a check i ain't
seeing music taking two years
you know what i'm gonna give off that
advance right had to live off just you
know what i'm saying the show that i had
you know what i'm saying and the [ __ ] i
had saved up and had to figure this [ __ ]
out and to the point where you know i'm
saying i did what i did and i cracked
you know i'm saying the conversation
with the with the with the uppers you
know and
[ __ ] got straightened well you're also
in a great position too because you have
like hits so no matter what there's
always a bag for you to get you know
what i'm saying
yeah even within in the building like
you can't tell me i ain't making no
money right you can't tell me i ain't
making no money all these [ __ ]
records you can't you can't yeah like
there's like not a lot of people are in
your position where they have that many
records where they could be like yo [ __ ]
the label i could just go
get 10 15 and get in your catalog yeah
let me just a lot of [ __ ] you can do now
yeah let me go hit the you know get the
back end of whatever club show maybe
straight yeah dolphin i'm running plays
dogs fear though i'm saying dog killing
that [ __ ] jesus christ you feel me yeah
that's it crazy yeah yeah yeah dolph's
on his [ __ ] man um is there anybody who
you said you went through it in like
2016 2017. anybody like any artists or
any any executives that kind of mentored
you through that that kind of was like
you know help help get you to the other
side oh yeah my management now you know
i'm saying shout out to madden you know
what i'm saying they they coached us and
really you know saying kept our spirits
huh when [ __ ] was you know saying kind
of rocky and [ __ ] so
it not not too many not too many ogs
came in and got it but the ones who did
you know sam failed were grateful
you know because we we really just we we
we tapped in and and took it upon
ourselves me and my business partner you
know i'm saying shout out to james
and and really figured this [ __ ] out mv
you know saying v was locked in with us
you know what i'm saying we were just
really like trying to figure out the
ways how the [ __ ] do we get out this
[ __ ] right and every day it was a as
soon as i wake up someone's out with my
eyes
we locked in on you know either we
recording or we
figuring out what the hell we gotta do
to get you know sent out [ __ ] so
it was everyday process man i i don't
regret it because i learned so much in
that time
you know what i'm saying as far as me
being you know saying
the ceo of my label i learned all the
ins and outs of tricks i'm still
learning but you know i'm saying you're
like i got so much information during
that time you mentioned that you moved
to la for a period of time which seems
like every artist does at some point in
time now so
um
is was that something that was like
beneficial to you because i feel like
sometimes people come to l.a just
because it's the thing to do it was it
was it was i'd say 50 50. when i came
out here we came out here you know
saying just due to
that was the beginning of my [ __ ] got
[ __ ] up when i came to la that was
when my [ __ ] was getting rocky and
landing on my management and all that
[ __ ]
ugly that's why i originally left like
all right
[ __ ] this let me get away from this let
me get out of here you know what i'm
saying then we came to l.a doing la [ __ ]
lit
partying right you know saying get lost
in the lifestyle till you know saying we
look back at atlanta we about a year and
a half at la light
then what the [ __ ] somebody else popping
or somebody up like you know what i'm
saying that [ __ ] don't ever stop you
know saying around this time 21 savage
is bubbling yeah yeah so we're like oh
it's a whole new [ __ ] vibe coming
through the city yeah i'm saying
and you could tell the energy was
different between you know saying people
that we once was cool with so we had to
pack our [ __ ] up in l.a because we saved
a lot of money on rent
boy yeah
went back to atlanta you know what i'm
saying kiss the babies you know what i'm
saying dude did you know what i'm saying
all the other relationships that was
[ __ ] up right
brought them back together the best way
we could
and you know said we've been in the city
ever since just building that [ __ ] yeah
tell everybody i feel like atlanta is
the one city in our industry in hip-hop
in our culture that is literally
you need atlanta you need it
like you can't like like atlanta is what
is is the taste maker of all cities
that's the one it don't matter who you
are you could be regional on the west
coast yeah you'll never be anything else
but a la or west coast artist unless you
go tapping with atlanta you got to tap
in man and and we knew that think about
yg right ygy
i remember and then the
cte [ __ ] happened and it might hit a
rich homie quasi
and that should put him on a whole
nother level exactly and and it worked
same way in atlanta you know what i'm
saying if you if you even came up in
atlanta for so long you still you could
look at it as atlanta artists now
atlanta don't need it uh i really don't
think atlanta needs la
because i think atlanta don't need la
but if you want to if you want to make
that bridge that gave me
you know it's the west coast it's the
west you guys that's a big ass market
but the way i look at it is atlanta
music isn't regional music it's just
everywhere yeah
if you go to the club in l.a
80 to 70 percent of the music you're
gonna hear is gonna either be from
atlanta yeah or from memphis yeah or
it's the south carolina style going
crazy period you know what i'm saying
now if you go to the club in atlanta
you're not going to know what you're not
going to hear the west coast shot here
you might hear something here right
ladies and gentlemen you're right
yeah you might yeah no but outside of
that if you like atlanta you go to new
york yeah you're going to hear 70 to 80
percent south music you're gonna hear
some new york [ __ ] for sure because
you're in new york
i think that's the difference you got a
point atlanta's sound is
the united states yeah but it's so
different though it's like
the sound change so fast down that
[ __ ] though it does it it does
but it also it does but it like that's
what makes
atlanta so important
um
that's what makes atlanta so important
because it dictates
the sound everywhere exactly you know
what i'm saying i i i agree with you 100
yeah my whole life and i just seen a lot
of this [ __ ] i was like man i don't
understand artists who don't go tapping
in atlanta yeah i'll be seeing like
you got to man that's an artist all
artists
there's an artist out here named kalin
for real for real who's my dog yeah he
did a great job of
going to the south first
tapping in with like
you know the homie dj win in florida and
going to atlanta and setting up i was
like yo that's low-key like you got to
do it that way yeah you're coming from
this side just like you know what i'm
saying but no that's the homie though
shout out to atlanta um
so this is your last album of as far as
interscope records this one the one i
buy to draw this one come out on the
13th and i got one more so you got okay
okay so this one coming out on the 13th
in my mind one more this one alright it
been done all right so it's done all
right and then from there you're gonna
you're gonna get back to the indie grind
i'm getting better in the grind let
somebody offer me a bag i can't refuse
that's fair as long as terms are right
yeah loans and turns right you know what
i'm saying because i know how to i know
how to stretch the money so you know
what i'm saying if anybody give me
what i'm when you say you know how to
stretch the money like what are some
things that you notice artists [ __ ]
money off on that you're like man you
don't really got to do that like i'm not
even talking about like jewelry or [ __ ]
i mean like
music [ __ ] like
it's just certain [ __ ] if you don't know
what to hear you you paying for you're
gonna get you know saying you're gonna
get finesse it's it's a finesse game we
we in the finances i still see artists
like cutting bags to uh people who will
get you blog placements you know yeah
like what you never [ __ ] you feel me
like like knowing and that's probably
just it don't matter if you don't know
what you're doing if you know if you
ain't gonna
say give me on complex for a thousand
dollars i'm like bro it doesn't matter
if you get on
complex 2012 it's not 2012 bro you might
want to do something viral and setting
yourself up in a viral network or
something for a thousand dollars and get
more clout how do you feel about like
just kind of like the way tick tock's
kind of
changing the way
i mean it's really changing music yeah
yeah it is have you had like a tick tock
moment yet where like you maybe hey i
busted top side of the head man lottery
was tit-top that was all tick-tock yeah
that [ __ ] was i was the one that opened
the flood was that on purpose like did
you put something
it just happened it happened organically
you know what i'm saying and and
you know the the downside of it i didn't
really get the benefits financially from
that because it was some new [ __ ] yeah
plus you don't right yeah yeah cause
that was a that was like a year and a
half ago yeah that was just some some
new [ __ ] so you know i didn't really get
to see the full
but
yeah man like we said that we said the
blueprint do you know we wanna we want a
cleo award for that do you um
see someone like t payne who's on tick
tock and on twitch like going crazy he's
hilarious yeah he's funny yeah do you
see [ __ ] like that in his
like because i feel like you know
if you
over expose yourself sometimes it could
be bad but if you got a great
personality and you got a lot like like
dope content to bring to the table it
could be a good thing yeah for sure
strengthen your brand is that something
like where you're like man i need to
maybe do more as far as getting my
personality getting who i am out there
more yeah i think about that all the
time you know i'm saying every day i'm
trying to figure out what's my niche
that i can just do it where i don't see
any force you know i'm saying like right
now i'm i'm heavy on youtube
you know saying i do float sessions i
bring my fans in
to my work you like stream
nah just just vlogs you know what i'm
saying just everyday lifestyle type [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i really do
that just to
get get a folks a new insight on kate
camp just not just almost me just
rapping and [ __ ] but as far as me being
on tit-top doing all that [ __ ] [ __ ] i
can't you know what i'm saying i ain't
got the time for it i don't either and i
don't want to know that it's someone
something i ain't like anybody be just
doing all that crazy [ __ ] just for some
i feel you bro i'm cool bro the tick
tock [ __ ] is it's it's a hard cookie
it's for me i haven't even cracked a
cookie it's a different world bro shout
out my girl monica she'll be doing all
my tick tocks she just takes pieces for
my interviews and post them but yeah
it's way see [ __ ] like that but i'll be
like i know that am i actually i want to
do some original like [ __ ] on there but
i every time i open it up i'm like man
i'm a grown ass man you feel me exactly
exactly but a lot of folks love that
[ __ ] man you know it worked for someone
you know
it don't work for some [ __ ] but
would you ever get on twitch and do the
gaming [ __ ] yeah do you play games yeah
2k call of duty hey man that's your fifa
2. that [ __ ] is a bag it is a bad uh my
manager was telling us about that they
paying force to uh to do it but listen
there's someone i know very well who's
an artist who got paid a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars
to play games for two hours and talk
about
7-elevens pizza for
during the just while he was playing
video games hey v let me get that
so you out there it was twitch
i need that 180k for two hours talking
about pizza on twitch you got to get
that to it that twitch is a movie yeah i
remember you said something about it a
couple weeks ago let's yeah do that
well look so the album um
after this album comes out what is the
timeline to get the other one out so
your out your deal um
i had a different timeline in my head
but it didn't work out like i thought it
was are you trying to get the the album
out before the end of the year your last
album rather
if i could i would
is it up to you or what the major label
thing do they gotta have green terms
it's the terms you know what i'm saying
you got to just
play play by the rules and the terms and
the agreements that everybody you know
saying agreed on but if i could i would
but i i say you know what i'm saying
quarter one uh q2 of next year around
that time i should be free mm-hmm the
last album probably came out i don't
wanna we're gonna see get your back on
empire you know what i'm saying shout
out to the empire shots
there it is man well look i appreciate
you pulling up um i don't know what
what's your single introduce it man for
the radio show uh right now i can't even
tell you the single once we drop the
album we're gonna let the fans listen
but the game ain't free game ain't free
pick a song to introduce for the radio
show for the radio show we're gonna get
our goods then now which one should we
get but by the way there's a song called
guts good is this about being inside of
a woman's guts
it's a line in the song saying that but
it ain't about to go okay yeah i'm
saying about it
hey man this is k count man this is guts
featuring true story t produced by
section 8 you know saying let's get into
it guts ladies and gentlemen yeah get
get some guts get some goods
every night perfect